i also want to thank believe it or not
medicated pete with his big dick energy
show that uh premiered this summer he
had a a panel discussion about penis he
had a porn star on there lisa ann and he
had a sex relationship expert on there
dr jen mann
a trans woman was there named mia
isabella remember miss cocktober we
named miss cocktober
yes but where pete fails i'll give him a
failing grade on small talk he he has a
hard time with that here she is
extremely beautiful lisa anne lisa
what's up
well it's great to be here with you the
other panelists be a part of this and
just be focused on you pete and your big
dick energy i appreciate that do you get
a boob job uh well many uh but are you
talking bigger or smaller because i am
smaller now than probably in which you
are bigger bigger no not bigger smaller
sorry sorry to let you down pete some
things like to go smaller that's right
i'm a boob guy so so um i
i love booms as well as [ __ ] okay so
that's what you're on today so
okay well thank you
yeah i know that i tell you he's
just weirdo but then he interviewed his
own mother about his large penis and i
found that fast really yeah i thought
that was pretty good mom how about when
i was a baby did it seem large too or
different
[Laughter]
[Music]
peter
when you were a baby
you were a baby you had i didn't notice
i i why would i notice that
i didn't notice anything that was
you know
stupendous and then you grew up and you
became a kid and you know i i it wasn't
like i was lurking around
watching you take a shower i'm not a
pervert you
you grew and and this is what happened
mom when you changed my diaper what was
the hardest thing about carrying from my
big penis
peter i just told you
it was just a normal baby
part okay
i i
there was nothing that's you know
stood out to me
pete's mom got fed up with the line of
questioning she hung up knowing now that
you know i have a big penis so i'm how
proud of you man
i'm i just
this whole
conversation is so
distasteful
so ridiculous it's embarrassing i'm
embarrassing myself by even sitting here
next to you
talking about this if anybody any of my
friends hear me in this conversation
they will drop me like a hot potato
they'll think i'm some kind of weirdo
okay
so are we done with our little chat
what do you say i inherited my my big
penis yeah peter peter peter
peter
it's over
i'm done
okay i did my duty i'm done
can i go
now one last portion yes deep down
inside
are you glad that a big penis is
supposed to be a small penis
peter i don't care
[Laughter]
can i go now
mom thanks thank you support thanks
okay it was great chatting with you and
don't ever ask me do this again bye-bye
good job there pete
you